[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight happy wednesday
parenthood is awesome but you learn a
lot if you ever had kids in middle
school you know what sustained emotional
drama looks like everything's fairly
placid up until about seventh grade and
then the four horsemen of the adolescent
apocalypse arrive hormones homework
dating and acne and things get very
volatile
very fast
the main symptom of this period of
childhood development apart from door
slamming is wild overstatement
no longer is anything okay or not very
good no
even the mildest inconvenience is
transformed into a horrifying world
ending disaster the titanic meets
vesuvius plus y2k
four minutes late for school is the
single worst day of my life ever
waking up before nine is like death
a pop quiz in math class that's the
emotional equivalent of ethnic cleansing
in bosnia except much more upsetting
it's pretty intense
thankfully most kids get over middle
school those who don't tend to leave
home and not come back they become
interpretive dance majors at small
liberal arts colleges or they run for
congress
ever wonder why america's traditional
party of the unionized working man
suddenly sounds like a van full of
eighth grade girls on the way to prom
all breathy and on the verge of tears
well it's simple because at this point
that's pretty much exactly what the
democratic party is
you really notice it in the way they
speak
for democrats there are no more small
problems no challenge is minor every
speed bump is a full-blown catastrophe
every disagreement total war
losing an election they can't even talk
about it
close your eyes and try to picture the
scariest threat you can imagine the
prowler at the door the monster under
the bed an irs audit
now multiply that scene by a million
sweat covered nightmares and you are
just beginning to approach the level of
terror the democrats feel when they
think about giving up power
it's not just a bad outcome it's the end
of
democracy
watch
is the end of our democracy insight and
i believe that the election of joe biden
essentially paused
our dissent uh in into just the complete
upending of our of our democracy but we
are not out of it so donald trump's come
back it's the end of our democracy we
might see the end of democracy in the in
the coming years so you're saying it's
still possible we could lose our
democracy here in the united states
without a doubt if americans lose faith
in the veracity and honor of our
elections
it's the beginning of end of our
democracy i think that could be the end
of our democracy not to be too
you know appointed about it but i want
people to understand hillary clinton
said a couple of weeks ago that if he
runs and wins that could be the end of
our democracy do you share that fear i
do
well i don't want to be overly alarmist
but i think we should be alarmed because
potentially this could be the end of
american democracy i never thought i'd
be saying something like that
it could be the end of american
democracy and i never thought i'd be
saying something like that says max boot
well that makes two of us we always knew
that max boot loved to kill brown people
in impoverished villages in far away
countries or precisely to send other
people's kids to do it for him but we
had no idea that max boot was in the
middle of a full-blown emotional
breakdown he must be because how else do
you explain a reaction like that
for a well-adjusted normal person
unwanted election outcomes are part of
life
voters don't always do what you want
them to do it is frustrating but that's
how it works
in fact when voters reject you you get a
chance to assess your own behavior
chances are there is a reason that
people didn't want you in power and you
now have time to think about what that
reason might be
that's a healthy process
so when you lose it is hardly proof that
the system is broken in fact it's
usually evidence that things are working
exactly as intended
but people like max bood and liz cheney
do not see it that way they are too
fragile to face their own unpopularity
to people like that the prospect of
rejection by voters of losing control of
the country
means literally literally literally the
end of democracy itself
imagine feeling that way
if you really believe that your election
loss meant the end of america and the
beginning of a thousand years of
darkness
you might have trouble keeping
perspective on politics
every election would feel like climate
change the most profound existential
crisis in the history of the world and
if your side ever lost an election whoa
how do you describe a disaster that
existentially existential honestly words
would fail you you'd have only animal
sounds
donald j trump is now president of the
united states
introduced for the first time ever
anywhere the 45th
president of the united states of
america
no
yes democrats someone you didn't vote
for won the presidential election
you know if you're not a democrat it's
pretty hard to imagine the pain of a
moment like that for democrats it was
like being boiled alive in a giant mug
of the world's hottest latte but without
the soothing foam
four years of wrenching agony
the whole experience hurts so much that
democrats inevitably came to the obvious
conclusion going forward no voter alive
or dead citizen or illegal should ever
again be asked to show voter id at the
polls
it was a simple elegant solution that no
sensible person could disagree with
unfortunately not everyone is sensible
many people are like hitler so they
oppose voter fraud democrats wasted no
time in becoming hysterical about this
watch
tonight's lead
jim crow 2.0 it is the most pernicious
thing this makes jim crow look like jim
eagle
our remnants of
jim crow i shouldn't even say remnants
revivals an attempted revival at jim
crow a jim crow kkk like caucus their
strategy right now is to pass a bunch of
racist voting laws effectively a new jim
crow in the south and allow republicans
all across the country to implement jim
crow 2.0 jim crow 2.0 this is jim jane
crow this is sally and and every other
crow that we can imagine
it's voter suppression it's the new jim
crow
that's right
showing photo id to vote says mr eric
michael dyson who not only teaches at a
college but has three names
that is both jim crow and jane crow and
for that matter very much like their
little known love child josephus crow
who's even more racist than his parents
are that's how immoral voter ideas so
stop it right now says eric michael
dyson it's the end of democracy
at this point a lot of things are the
end of democracy including we are here
to tell you not wearing a mask in an
elevator
yes
that's the end of democracy two so says
the latest bulletin from and we want to
be clear here we're not accusing anyone
of hysteria just reporting the news
from this sitting democratic
congresswoman who in point of fact
really sits but instead leaps around
pointing her finger at people and
accusing them of things in any case here
she is explaining the latest threats to
democracy
this has happened to me where you get on
an elevator and people refuse to wear a
mask and your choices are to either get
off the elevator or to get on the
elevator and to tell them to wear a mask
that should not be a problem in the
united states congress and uh i really
believe that our colleagues who refuse
to even adhere to the basic norms of
civility are undermining our democracy
and of course we're seeing it in all
kinds of even more serious ways like the
january 6th insurrection
so those are your choices with an
insurrectionist gets on the elevator
without a math of course the other
choice is to seek immediate psychiatric
care and behave like an adult that has
not occurred to them
because democracy is at stake it turns
out you can destroy our ancient
democracy just by forgetting to wear
your mask in an elevator
think about that for a moment mr mrs
america our democracy is that brittle
one act of carelessness and it could
shatter into a million pieces like a
priceless vase
it's enough to keep you up at night adam
kinser has not slept since he realized
that the thought that some oath might
trip on a carpet edge and drop democracy
onto a hardwood floor literally
literally
makes adam kinzinger cry
that's how sensitive he is watch
i never expected a day to be
quite as emotional for me as it has been
you know you talk about the impact of
that day
but you guys won
you guys held
you know democracies
are not defined
by our bad days
we're defined by how we come back from
bad bad days
yes another seventh grade girl
representing you in congress ladies and
gentlemen mr adam kinzinger you've got
to wonder if we would all be much better
off if adam kinser had just stuck to
interpretive dance too late now i'm
steve ducey i'm brian killman and i'm
ainsley earhardt and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis